next question is about Joe Biden Donald
Trump and Utah David if Mitt Romney
endorses Biden could Biden win Utah so
the answer is no the short answer is no
and the background for the question I
understand there was recently a poll
that showed in very very right-wing
conservative Utah Donald Trump winning
only by three points the idea about MIT
Romney is MIT Romney is a Republican
senator from Utah Mitt Romney's Mormon
Utah has a big warm in population
Mormons maybe what while
disproportionately Republican voters
they also may just follow what Mitt
Romney does if Mitt Romney says hey vote
for Biden could it turn Utah against
Donald Trump I don't I don't see it I
think the best case scenario would be if
Mitt Romney does endorse Joe Biden that
it makes Utah so competitive that Trump
has to spend money there and then that
means there's less money Trump can spend
in other places but the truth is that
since the year 2000 the only Democrat to
carry more than 30% even in Utah was
Obama in 2008 and he's still lost like
in other words Democrats often don't
even get 30 in Utah and when Obama did
he's still lost very very significantly
the best we can hope for is that Mitt
Romney makes it a fight for Donald Trump
and now there is one other thing to
think about here imagine if Mitt Romney
ran third party that actually could take
away enough from Trump and Utah that it
could play spoiler essentially and turn
it over to Joe Biden but the problem is
that if Mitt Romney ran third party he'd
be running third party I don't think he
would just run in Utah and he would risk
in places like Michigan and Wisconsin
and others giving the election
potentially potentially to Donald Trump
we just don't know it would be dicey and
I would be worried about it so I think
the best thing job Mitt Romney can do is
seems unlikely he's going to support
Donald Trump if he is going to
support Joe Biden just say it and I
think that that is all we can really
hope for and make Utah a fight make
Trump spend some money you know we talk
about what's going on with Amy McGrath
and Mitch McConnell in that Senate race
in Kentucky I it's possible Amy McGrath
could win it's an uphill battle in a
recent poll she was up one but with a
huge number of undecided and people not
yet really paying that much attention I
hope she wins but even if she doesn't if
it's this close Republicans will
probably have to funnel a bunch of
national money into Kentucky to defend a
seat that has historically been very
very safe for Republicans that's still
good even if you don't end up winning
the seat so that that's my take right
now I don't think there's any real way
that Joe Biden wins Utah but let's make
a Trump fight for it why not